and this session is on John's Jews and
their effective force in reception
history first apresenta is Adele
rinehart's well known here she's a
professor in the Department of classics
and religious studies at the University
of Ottawa and Canada and general editor
of the journal of biblical literature
her main areas of research our new
testament early jewish-christian
relations the bible and film and
feminist biblical criticism she's the
author of numerous articles and books
including befriending the Beloved
Disciple a Jewish reading of the Gospel
of John scritch scripture on the silver
screen Jesus of Hollywood Caiaphas the
high priest and Bible and cinema in
introduction Adele was elected to the
Royal Society of Canada in 2005 into the
American Academy of Jewish research in
2014 please join me in welcoming at the
line how it's backed feel very much very
happy to be here and to want to thank
the organizers for including me in this
very interesting event and one that's
close to my own heart and the core of my
research as well the Gospel of John ends
with a heartfelt lament about the
limitations of time and space that pose
a perpetual challenge to historians and
most other scholars now how does one
sorry I just want to move this forward
on a map or maybe like this there we go
okay too many books there are also many
other things that Jesus did this is the
ending of chapter 21 of the of the
fourth gospel if every one of them were
written down I suppose the world itself
could not contain the books that would
be written and here the author of the
fourth gospel or at least of this
chapter echoes the sentiments of an
earlier biblical writer Co helot who
complained that of making many books
there is no end and much study is a
weariness of the flesh I think there is
no other topic in johanan studies that
is generated quite as many books as a
topic of anti Judaism given the mere 25
minutes at my disposal today I'm going
to focus on only one verse which is John
844 and it reads like this you are from
your father the devil this is Jesus
talking to Jews you are from your father
the devil and you choose to do your
father's desires he was a murderer from
the beginning and does not stand in the
truth because there is no truth in him
when he lies he speaks according to his
own nature for he is a liar and the
father of lies we cannot escape I think
the anti-semitic legacy of this
statement and I'm just going to share
with you a number of images that I
pulled off the internet just a few days
ago these are devil Jews
on the internet very you know recent
images Satan at the Wailing Wall we have
a magane daveed with the devil in the
middle and a cartoon from a newspaper
called al-hayat uh yeah dude I don't
know how to pronounce that exactly the
official palestinian authority daily
which again has a devil jun imagery as
well and in addition to what you find on
the internet we oh and this is another
one i wanted to show you which I was
very interested in this is a website
called Jewish creeps using the New
Testament and it's on this volume of the
annotated New Testament that I and many
other Jewish New Testament scholars
contributed to with the two editors mark
Brett ler and Amy Jill Levine and what
was of interest to me is the fact that
John age 44 is quoted right on the web
page so it's not exactly an academic
question as some people might not some
people in this room but I've encountered
those who would say that and it's an
association that lives on in many
different ways and in many different
places including at the movies and I
just want to show you one a clip from
mel gibson's famous or infamous film
that brings jewish devil children to
life before our eyes
Oh
when I first saw the film The Passion of
the Christ and I saw this scene it
really blew me away and what you
probably couldn't see because of the
color and you know the quality of the of
the clip is that those little children
those boys are wearing he put and that's
what really astounded me that you have
little Jewish children wearing keep odd
that turn into demons before your eyes
now of course in the film this is a
figment of Judas's imagination but those
images are there and they're just out
there and visible to anybody who to
watch is this film now the contemporary
use of John 844 did not arise in a
vacuum rather has a long history
starting perhaps as early as the book of
Revelation which refers in these two
verses to the synagogue of Satan there's
a lot of debate as to what is actually
meant there we don't know whether the
author was borrowing from directly from
the fourth evangelist we also don't know
exactly what those verses are meant to
represent but the associations of Jews
and Satan at least is clear and there
may also be an allusion to this and
first John 3 12 which reads with me not
we must not be like Cain who was from
the evil one and murder his brother and
why did he murder him because his own
deeds were evil and his brothers
righteous and there's in the in
patristic literature and elsewhere there
is an association between Jews Cain and
Satan that maybe somehow related to this
verse the tendency to connect juice
is a tested and patristic and other post
New Testament text as well just have a
few examples here this is her acting on
whose work is preserved in fragments and
I'm not going to go through all of these
but these are all examples of passages
in a post New Testament literature that
pick up on the language of the Gospel of
John and extend it further so that's
correctly on we have here along a
quotation again which I won't read to
you and you won't have time to read it
but it does associate Jews and the devil
in a way that is really fairly absolute
and again in John Chrysostom so given
and then there's a lot of imagery and
really way more material and I could
possibly present from the Middle Ages
and here I've relied on the work of
Joshua trachtenberg who wrote a book
called the devil in the Jews he wrote
this book was published by yale
university press in 1943 and clearly
under the shadow of what was happening
in Europe at that time and this I am
going to read if the Jews today despised
and feared and hated it is because we
are the heirs of the Middle Ages if it
is possible for demagogues to sow the
seeds of disunion and discord to stir
fanatical emotions asset neighbor
against neighbor it is because the
figure of the demonic jus less than
human indeed anti-human the creation of
the medieval mind still dominates the
folk imagination clearly here speaking
about Nazi Germany and other expressions
of anti-semitism in the 20th century
given this rich medieval background and
Luther's own use of Satan imagery when
discussing the Jews it is not surprising
perhaps and here I have this on the Jews
and their lives he uses these same
material
it's not surprising that john 844 found
its way into nancy posters and
propagandas so here we have Luther here
we have a range of medieval these are
wood cuts or other illustrations some
from illuminated Bibles and we have here
the quotation from The Merchant of
Venice that I used as my title and here
I have two images for which I thank Ruth
Sheridan for drawing my attention to
these these are examples of the use of
John 844 in Nazi signage and in the
first one it says whoever knows the Jews
knows the devil and in the in the large
one it says that the father of the jews
is the devil so clearly relying here on
John 844 I think this makes the notion
of the legacy or the ability to deny the
legacy of age 44 pretty difficult you
would have caught you have of a constant
stream of usage from the ancient period
to the present day now few scholars
would deny that John 844 as well as
other sections of the fourth gospel have
been interpreted in ways that promote
fear of and hostility towards Jews far
more contentious is the question of
whether this impact was an unintended
consequence the imposition of
anti-jewish attitudes on a text that had
no anti-jewish intentions or whether the
gospel itself can be described as
anti-jewish and if so in what sense and
this is where things get hot and heavy
in johanan studies around this question
most New Testament scholars absolve the
Gospel of John itself of the charge of
anti Judaism and I'll just site here a
couple of scholars urban bon vol day for
example insist quote that the variance
two of the passage and here's talking
about John eight must be distinguished
from the passages original meaning as it
can be historically constructed we do no
justice to early Christianity or to the
authors of the gospel or to Christianity
itself if we fail to do this our sins
were not their sins rognvald a and other
scholars justify their benign reading of
the gospel through recourse to Sanders
historical-critical methodology if we
would only situate the gospel in its
proper literary social and historical
context they suggest we would see that
it could not have been anti-jewish with
regard to 844 this argument takes two
major forms the prophetic and what I've
called the conventional that is relying
on ancient conventions the prophetic
approach argues that John 8 must be
understood in the context of Biblical
prophecy like Isaiah Jeremiah and the
other major prophets Jesus called upon
others to mend their ways lest they be
punished by God the goal of such
prophecies not to curse or diable eyes
these others but to prod them into
repentance I have an example here by
Henry coat when Jesus calls his
listeners children of the devil one
cannot speak of a dilation of the Jews
any more than one can suspect the Jews
adea fying themselves when they say they
are God's children Jesus points only at
their devilish nature in dividing
destroying and killing it is not the
Jews themselves that are depicted as
Devils but because they in fact perform
the works of or the will of the devil
they are on his side they are devilish
because they so division and kill people
so it's not the Jews but their actions
Jesus reproach is not an expression of
enmity but it's an attempt to make them
realize what they are doing it's a
prophetic explanation of events in the
hope that is listeners
repent and then along the same lines we
have Steven ma ma chair claims that
predictions of judgment and warning are
issues so that they might not be
fulfilled even if you are even if the
phrase you are of your father the devil
becomes in its context even sorry even
you're of your father the devil becomes
in its context a passionate appeal to
change direction the polemic of John 8
serves not merely to denounce but to
warn to persuade to prompt its own
negation now the postmodern side of me
likes the idea of a text prompting its
own negation I personally don't think
that that's what's happening here but in
any case this is exemplifies a
particular type of approach the IV what
I call the prophetic approach a second
approach is to argue that what John is
doing here is simply relying on standard
stereotypical polemical language of
ancient Mediterranean societies this
approach relies heavily on an article
published by Luke timothy johnson in the
journal biblical literature in 1989 in
this article Luke Johnson surveys
ancient polemics and concludes that the
slander of the New Testament is typical
of that found among rival claimants to a
philosophical tradition the way the New
Testament talks about Jews is the way
all opponents talked about each other
back then the main things such slander
signified says Johnson was that someone
was an opponent this has really become
very popular in my field and I'll just
give a couple of examples of involved a
adopts this approach for John 844 which
in his view simply restates the basic
conviction that because his opponents
don't accept what they had what he has
to say they are doing wrong and are
there was Jesus opponents when he says
they're not of God that they're not of
truth that their follower of the father
of lies he's using a series of
categories which his reader would
immediately recognized as a standard
type of apocalyptic argument the reader
would certainly understand that the
writer recognized the other group as an
opponent and was accusing them of doing
evil they would also recognize that the
argument had no more hostility to it
than other case and been any other case
an apocalyptic polemic so this is a way
of defusing I suppose the emotion that
seems to us perhaps to underline John
egg by saying well you know in the
ancient world nobody really would have
thought twice about it when then wanders
the why the church fathers went to town
they were after all readers of this
gospel and yet did not seem to respond
in the same way in any case not everyone
differentiates so sharply between the
text and its reception history and
eyesight here Judith Lou who explains
that recent developments in literary and
hermeneutical analysis have made it much
more difficult to think of a text as
something that can be separated
conceptually from its interpreters in
the same way the idea of authorial
intention as something accessible
through a text has also become highly
problematic and so she goes further on
to talk about the inseparability of text
and interpretation and so the history of
interpretation becomes part of the
meaning of the text for subsequent
interpreters and I think this is a very
important point that is helpful in
understanding this passage we cannot
free ourselves from this or disregarded
this is Leo now and this must be
particularly true of a text that has
functioned and continues to function as
a canonical text we operate within an
interpretive tradition and one which has
not functioned merely as an intellectual
tapas but which has been articulated in
practice with destructive
so Judah Theo's comments exposed the
attempt to distinguish between text and
interpretation as superficial naive and
apologetic her comments also suggest
that the anti-jewish readings of the
church fathers Luther and later
interpreters including Hitler and Mel
Gibson actualize a potential that is
inherent in the gospel itself on these
grounds it is not only the reception
history but the gospel itself that is
anti-jewish now I agree with you on the
inseparability of texin interpretation I
would also add that insofar as the
gospel in my view intends to distance at
least functions to distance the audience
from non-believing or non-christian Jews
and even to foster hostility towards
them the gospel itself is anti-jewish to
develop this point I just want to look
briefly at John 844 in its context
within chapter 8 so I go back now to 8
31-32 then jesus said to the Jews who
had believed in him if you continue in
my word you are truly my disciples and
you will know the truth and the truth
will make you free this verse fits into
the johannine motif of inadequate faith
that is present throughout the entire
gospel starting at least from the second
chapter and the antecedent in terms of
you know if you look at who are these
Jews who had believed in him the median
antecedent seems to be a reference in
chapter 7 verses 42 43 about a division
in the crowd when some heard these words
they said this is really the Prophet
when others heard them they said this is
the Messiah but some said surely the
Messiah does not come from Galilee half
of the scripture said that the Messiah's
descended from David so there was a
division in the
crowd because of him and so that means
that there were some Jews who listened
who did who had believed and but maybe
we're still kind of wavering now some
scholars wish to limit the applicability
of the discourse as a whole to this
group but in my view that doesn't change
very much at all because the entire
discourse draws upon motifs that are
present throughout the gospel and that
are not tied to a particular subgroup of
the of the Jews so I want to look more
specifically at what's going on in
Chapter eight Jesus challenges the Jews
to deepen their understanding and to
commit more fully by continuing in Jesus
word that's what we have we take a look
now at 8 31-32 he says if you continue
in my word you're truly my disciples you
will know the truth the truth shall set
you free the Jews in effect reject the
challenge so if they would accept the
challenge they would have knowledge of
the truth from that knowledge would flow
freedom but they reject the challenge
because they deny that they are in need
of such liberation and they provide
three reasons to support their
perspective they claim to be descendants
of Abraham they claim never to have been
slaves to anyone and they claim to have
one father God himself in effect the
Jews appeal to their covenant old
relationship with God which they enjoyed
by virtue of their genealogy their
commitment to monotheism and their
election as God's chosen people just as
a side comment commentators get very
caught up in the question of whether the
Jews are lying here when they say that
never been slaves to anyone because they
say well they were slaves they were
slaves in Egypt and so the Jews are
lying and showing even more so that they
deserve this title of being children of
the devil my own view is that they're
actually talking about slavery in the
sense of idolatry versus monotheism the
temperature of the discourse heats up
when Jesus denies them
these claims the Jews are not children
of Abraham he says because they don't do
what their father did the child of
Abraham welcomes Jesus perhaps as the
biblical Abraham welcomed his three
heavenly visitors and believed their
prophecies concerning his own future son
and the destruction of Sodom and
Gomorrah this is Genesis 18 to 19 which
i think is and others many others as
well underlies some of the discourse in
John 8 though the Jews claim not to have
served anyone or anything in fact they
are slaves to sin according to Jesus and
as slaves shall not remain in their
father's house only the one who
continues in Jesus worked except sima's
and accepts him as a truth can be truly
free a child of God loves Jesus and
knows that he has been sent by the
father so far from being children of God
the Jews behavior as murderers and Liars
reveals that the devil is their true
father Jesus not only denies the Jews
entitlement to these coven ental
identity markers but he also
appropriates them for himself I just
want to be clear that I'm not talking
about Jesus as a historical individual
I'm talking about Jesus as is
constructed by presented in the Gospel
of John Jesus is not a mere child of
Abraham that he existed before and was
celebrated by abraham a 56 58 Jesus not
only achieves freedom but provides
freedom for others Jesus not only a
child of God but is the only son of God
the one who has full and legitimate
access to God's house so these are the
ways in which Jesus appropriates the
same covenant cyl claims for himself so
in this section of 8 31 and following
the narrator strips the Jews of their
voice and Jesus denies them both
features that are central to their own
self understanding as articulated in
this passage
now the question then is are the
commentators to say that it's the Jews
deeds that are vile correct in
distinguishing between the deeds and the
Jews essence this is one of the central
points that is made by by many scholars
I would argue that in this passage it is
not just that the Jews do bad things it
is that they are in their essence of
demonic a satanic I should say rather
than divine origin the refusal to
believe shows that they are covenant to
relationship with God and their status
as a divinely chosen people is a lie and
if they are not God's children they must
be Satan's when the Johanna and Jesus
accuses the Jews of having the devil as
their father he is not merely making a
rhetorical statement a convention
adhering to an ancient convention of
labeling his opponents on the contrary
he is making a statement that he
considers to be factually true based on
how the gospel writer and I believe many
others of his day understood the process
of reproduction in other words what is
our relationship to our fathers in a
genealogical sense among the many
reproductive theories put forward an
ancient philosophical and scientific
literature the most widespread at this
time was Aristotle's theory of
epigenesis as articulated in his
treatise on the generation of animals
according to this theory animals and
human beings grow organically not part
by part from the sperm of the mail as
set within the medium of growth provided
by the female the male semen determines
the form of the embryo as well as the
process by which it reaches maturity in
Aristotle's view the degree and nature
of the resemblance between parents and
offspring are determined by competition
between the male and female principles
in the early stages of the generative
process in ideal circumstances as in the
case of God and God's Son the male
principle will father a son who's
identical to himself in all respects and
it's in this sense that the father and
the son are one which is a statement
made in the Gospel of John so when when
the Gospel of John identifies Jesus as
the Son of God he means it it in a kind
of a very concrete material way in
addition to all of its spiritual
connotations and the Sun can do the
things that the father does because he
has reproduced the father precisely in
this perfect process of reproduction the
gospel uses the language of generation
to describe not only those who become
legitimate children of God such as Jesus
and those who believe in Jesus but also
those who claim to be so and in fact are
not now as we've seen the confrontation
between Jesus and the Jews revolves at
least in part around competing
genealogical assertions so the Jews
claim Abraham as their father in 839 and
in 841 they traced a genealogy back even
further to God and then Jesus says if
God were your father you would love me
for I proceeded and came forth from God
ok so this is the language of generation
of reproduction I came not of my own
accord but he sent me because their
behavior does not resemble that of
Abraham ur of God Jesus denies their
claim to be children of Abraham and of
God so Jesus argument in this case
appeals to the belief that paternity is
attested by the likeness or similarity
between father and son and so the gospel
uses the theory of epigenesis to
delineate the boundaries between those
who are
in the community and those who are
outside it those within belong socially
and even organically that is by means of
divine generation to the children of God
those outside though they may claim to
be divinely begotten are in fact
children of the devil so their behavior
is what demonstrates that they
organically generate a generative leary
productively the children of the devil
not again it's not simply name-calling
or an ancient form of polemics so I
don't know why I couldn't resist this
this is a child of the devil which I
think exemplifies the kind of innocence
that can be or maybe just to lighten the
mood a little bit when the Johanna and
Jesus calls the Jews children of the
devil he is not merely engaging an
ancient name calling nor is he calling
in my view for repentance rather he's
making a metaphysical statement rooted
in genealogy why they behave yours the
son of god they arch the Jews are
treating the Son of God in the same way
that the devil treats or would like to
treat God in behaving like the devil the
Jews show that they share in the devil's
essence in other words that they are
children of the devil it is obvious but
later readers of John from the church
fathers to present-day anti-semites read
John 8 in precisely this way some might
argue that such readers failed to read
John 8 correctly that is within its
proper historical and literary context
but if Judith Lou is correct and
stressing the inseparability of meaning
and interpretation those hostile
interpretations in fact actualize
anti-jewish tendencies that are inherent
in the gospel itself and if I'm
incorrect in seeing the role of
Aristotelian epigenesis here I think
that it goes deeply into the mindset at
least created by this gospel
if not necessarily we can't know the
intentions of the author the very
difficult question of what Christians
who sacred Canon includes as damaging
text should do with or about such
passages is thankfully beyond the scope
of my talk today beyond the scope of art
of our conference I would merely suggest
that those of us who affiliate with
communities that have sacred texts are
called upon not so much to accept them
unthinkingly or to cover over there
blemishes of apologetics but to wrestle
with them and if need be to resist their
biases and judgments thank you our next
panelist is Ruth Sheridan who comes to
us from Australia where she took her
doctorate of the Australian Catholic
University in 2011 with a dissertation
on the fourth gospel entitled retelling
Scripture the Jews and scriptural
citations in John 119 through 12 15
published by Berlin 2012 for that work
Ruth end-2013 was given the Manfred
lautenschlager award for theological
promise some of you may know this award
by his earlier name the templeton prize
she is currently a postdoctoral research
fellow at the Charles Sturt University
in New South Wales Australia and is
currently at work on a monograph on the
figure of Abraham in John 8 to be
published by tnt Clark I came to know
Ruth and her work when I was in
Australia two years ago it gives me
great pleasure to welcome her to the atl
okay so delight to be here and I just
want to thank the organizers and however
inviting me so today might the title of
my talk is reproducing Jonah
anti-judaism the case of commentaries on
John 832 so let me begin by just
explaining how i came to this topic so
i'm currently writing a book on John 8 a
text that's long been regarded as one of
the most vitriolic in the New Testament
in terms of its portrayal of the Jews
however my focus today isn't on the
gospel text itself but on one aspect of
the texts legacy that I became aware of
in the course of researching my book I
began to notice a particular
interpretive trend in many of the gospel
commentaries on John 8 32 which Adela's
already referred to in her talk this
trend is alarming both for its
prevalence and its longevity and it
appears to have become partially
entrenched in the commentary genre but I
think it has resonance with and maybe
even roots in anti-semitic systems of
thought that emerged in early modern
Europe so what is the substance of this
interpretive trends oh hang on yes let's
take a look at the gospel text to gain
our bearings for a minute again Adela's
already brought this up on her slide so
I don't have to go into a lot of detail
but basically the context in the gospel
shows that a debate is beginning to
emerge between Jesus and the Jews who
had believed in him and jesus promises
them that if they remain in his word
they'll be his disciples they'll come to
know the truth and the truth will set
them free the Jews reply we are
descendants
seed of Abraham and have never been
slaves to anyone what do you mean by
saying you'll be made free and jesus
answered very truly I tell you everyone
who commits sin is a slave to sin now
this bracket at those last two words
because not all manuscript to test them
now I've underlined verse 33 because
that's where this interpretive trend
that I've identified what where it
centers upon it focuses on the Jews
response in verse 33 and characterizes
it not as me indignation and certainly
not as a legitimate counterclaim but as
a perverse embodiment of Jewish
nationalism pride privilege and
Prejudice these readings in the
commentaries exacerbate the already
pejorative characterization of the Jews
in John 8 so they basically cluster
around the core trade of the Jews
apparent pride that's a strongly
recurrent term in the modern
commentaries but commentators will also
describe the Jews boasting complacency
self delusion and error and other more
malignant traits include they're lying
there abelian their legalism and even
their infidelity to the Covenant now I
found this particularly striking because
the immediately preceding verses Jesus's
words about liberating truth have had a
luminous reception history of their own
one major commentator referred to that
verse as quote one of the most
magnificent join and phrases which to
this day have lost nothing of their
radiance and yet the reply of the Jews
in verse 33 elicit some of the most
invidiously judgmental language in the
commentaries now of course not all of
the commentaries took this path there
were certainly exceptions and we'll try
to look at those as well and explain
them a little and I should just say here
that this project represents work in
progress and that the handout that you
have in front of you basically shows you
that the range of modern gospel
commentaries is very extensive and very
large so I'm showing you today only
what I've been able to consult so far
and basically these are the ones that
are in English and German most of them
are considered standards in the field
many of them and have a high impact on
the study of John's Gospel even today
okay but before looking at some of those
examples I just want to note that modern
critical countries are not regularly
considered part of the Gospels reception
history and I'm thinking with Jo
Jeanette here the French literary
theorist commentaries are metal ettore
informant functions they're part of
academic discourse they're not creative
transformations of the primary text and
as such presumably deserving of careful
analysis in the manner of a painting
story or a sculpture but I want to
challenge this intuitive objection and
claim that the gospel commentary ought
to be studied in its own right and its
genre ought to be theorized indeed it's
precisely the commentaries metal it
reform that sharpens the problem I'm
addressing because the commentary
invites itself to be read as an
exegetical tool and as a resource
presenting as a standard reference work
and it functions as a compliment or
companion to the gospel text almost of
necessity adopting a compliant reading
position with respect to the text
message about Jesus commentaries often
except the normativity of the canonical
text in positive terms the commentary
augments the gospel text adding to it
transforming its meaning and the process
of expert ating it and it acts as a
supplement to the gospel text it might
even for many students or readers
replace a reading of the primary text in
the in the guild and in the community
sometimes its supreme authoritative
pneus is taken for granted and finally
the modern commentary has a
multi-faceted market and can be
disseminated to the widest possible
audience so it's therefore troubling to
find that so many commentaries adopt
this stereotype reading of the Jews in
the
33 under the guise of the authority due
to its form the gospel commentary can
smuggle in ideology so let's take a look
at some of the earliest countries I've
broken this down into three periods so
one of the earliest ones I could find
was by a german scholar this one had
been translated into english 1868 and he
says that the jews response here shows
them to be full of empty pretensions
that the jews boasted of their freedom
while they still found themselves in the
vilest slavery the slavery of sin he
says the Doozers supposedly of the world
needed to be delivered from slavery by
Jesus and that this must have been
humbling for them and i put in brackets
there this this world of LT dentin which
calls up the sort of stereotyped
anti-semitic notion in the eighteenth
and nineteenth centuries in germany
which is sort of conspiracy theory which
saw Jews as a sort of plutocratic world
power trying to take over the world I
would suggest that perhaps that that is
influencing Hansen Bowes reading there
and then we see Westcott one of the
first English british commentators on
the text saying that the jews response
is their claim to religious privilege
that their inability to hear Christ four
trays and springs from a close affinity
with the powers of evil their claim to
be seed of Abraham was their national
boast and acclaimed of sovereignty of
the world there we have that trope again
Bernard reprinted four times but I think
initially 1928 said that this claim to
be seed of Abraham was the proudest
boast of the Jews and it was a petulant
retort to Jesus's offer of freedom now
possibly the most influential comment
commentator on the Gospel of John maybe
even today was Rudolph
and he wrote and published his German
commentary in 1941 and it's never gone
out of print he writes that the Jews
hold it higher freedom as the
characteristic of the Jew who already
has it in his possession in virtue of
his being a child of Abraham he
continues by saying the Jews commit
themselves to their loss condition they
are blind man who think that they can
see and this continued on in the
post-war period and again here I've got
Rudolph's neck and Berg another very
influential German commentator on the
text he says Jesus's words would have
wounded their religious and national
pride so again that motif of pride
emerging and another quote the Jews
pride and complacency a clean contrary
to the attitude which would make them
receptive to Jesus's message Raymond
Brown a very own virtual Catholic
American commentator on the gospel also
called upon this kind of language by
calling it the Jews ill-founded boast as
the privileged heirs to the promise to
Abraham now admittedly in context Browns
language is more tempered than that of
his contemporaries but those words are
still down and tension another German
commentator whose work was translated
into English has written that the Jews
appear to be free but they will really
be free only as Christians only
questions need not fear condemnation
tensions common tree is a very respected
in a very respected series Herman AO and
has been influential ck Barrett Charles
Barrett British commentator rights or he
begins well in fact he sort of
established as a critical distance
between what the Jews are saying in the
text and he says you know these words
put into the mouth of the Jewish
objectors but he does continue to give
his judgment he says this very claim
uttered in human pride over against the
representative of God Himself is an
instance of the bondage referred to in
verse 34 that is it's indicative of
their slavery
sin and he continues here they are
confident that they are free men and
have no need of a liberator and this is
kind of particular motif of needing a
savior or needing a liberator continues
to emerge later on in commentaries by
Linda and Ellis but for constraints of
time I won't go into that now George
Beasley marine has written the
commentary in the 1980s and he takes
things in a new direction he says that
the wider Prickett be John 8 30 to 59
represents quote a typical statement of
Jews coming to faith in Jesus they are
instructed by him has to work true
discipleship means and there follows a
mass of typical Jewish propaganda
calculated to destroy faith in Jesus he
sees the lib situation out of which this
text emerged as a conflict not with
Judaizers another quote but with Judaism
and then he continues this idea of the
boasting the Jews response was the most
of the rabbi's now the 1990s was a very
prolific period in terms of the
production of commentaries it was also
quite surprising to see that the trope
of Jewish pride continued to be
expressed even as late as the 1990s
particularly after some very important
work by EDD Sanders you would think that
it would have time to filter down into
the discipline where he reconsidered a
lot of this sort of stereotyped
anti-jewish readings of the New
Testament but an increased sensitivity
to the perils of anti-jewish exegetical
interpretation doesn't seem to have
affected the commentaries at this point
so Donald passes views are particularly
disturbing he writes that the Jews are
unwilling to recognize their own slavery
to sin nor indeed the fickleness that
oscillates between hero worship and
massive discontent it goes on to talk
about their inherited privilege their
refusal to recognize
word and he understands Jesus's
reference to slavery as a vicious
slavery to moral failure to rebellion
against the God who made us the despotic
master is not Caesar but shameful
self-centeredness and evil and enslaving
diversion to creative things at the
expense of worship of the Creator our
carstens pastoral commitments are not
hidden he definitely brings back to the
fore in his preface but I think that his
application of tax has the effect of
extending his comments about the evil
and self-centered use of John 8 to
present non-believers those he deems
guilty of moral failure he also goes on
to call the Jews claim to be seed of
Abraham a fundamental religious bias
that ought to give way in the presence
of Jesus he again reduces this notion of
fickle mob psychology and ultimately he
determines that they have no real heart
for God or sensitivity to his voice
Herman Rita boss again writing what he
called a theological commentary on the
gospel referred to the Jews
characteristic limitations in the
following quote their faith had to fit
into the framework of their Jewishness
and could not be allowed to violate what
was fundamental for them in that
Jewishness in context he's talking about
monotheism but he goes on to give this
juicy part here the Jews objection arose
from a sense of spiritual superiority as
children of Abraham chosen by God out of
all the nations and then he likens the
Jews of John 8 to contemporary people
living in a state of illusion or what he
calls illusion regarding they suppose
itself autonomy
now one of the most disturbing ones that
i found was by this author Thomas Brody
published by oxford university press in
1993 this one is riddled with problems
we haven't got time to go into them all
so I've just picked out a few he starts
by identifying the juice of John 832 as
those who are quote following the
enslaved tradition of Judaism and he
says again with a concern of making an
application to the present they
represent all those who abused religion
and all who in place of genuine
believing substitute some form of
triviality superstition Idol or lie then
he brings up what he calls a proverb
although it's uncited and I don't know
where he's got it from and he says the
corruption of the best is the worst it
shows that the corruption of religion
and religion like believes provides a
place where evil may flourish I think
it's hard to comprehend how such
injudicious language could have escaped
the editorial red pen this recalls the
scholarly constructive late Judaism beta
Denton a corrupt devolution airy form of
a suppose of pristine prezi like
religion with the most destructive
aspect of birdies text is his depiction
of the Jews as evil an inexcusable
interpretive option in light of the
history of Western anti-semitism which
retain the Associated Jews with the
devil now the implication of roadies
text is that bridget is that the
rejection of Jesus's offer of freedom
indicates that human propensity towards
evil I'll skip over the next quote that
I've got up there but you can see in
fact to give it a little bit of context
Brody relies on works of popular
psychology to make his generalized
assertions here and I'll just move on to
the present
okay between 2000 and the present day I
noticed fewer examples of these kinds of
interpretations in the commentaries one
could therefore hope that the passage of
time is coincident with a greater
awareness of the problems inherent in
these kinds of exaggerated
interpretations but I did find two
exceptions one in 2010 both published by
Edmonds which is I think a scholarly
evangelical publishing house John Ramsey
Michaels writes that the Jews
conspicuously ignore Moses's words but
they're simply on he said that he can
see is that they are simply expressing a
kind of national pride and there doesn't
seem to be any pejorative connotation
when he says that but even so their
disclaimer misses the point and then he
says that the wider context calls into
question their faithfulness to their own
covenant even more problematic as of
2012 commentary by Dale Bruner and now
Dale burner reads the Jews of John 832
as converts this kind of falls in line
with a reading tradition that sees the
Jews who had believed in him as a subset
of Jews Jewish Christians and therefore
converts and so that explains the way he
approaches a passage here and he says
these believers bring too much
self-confidence to their conversion they
don't think they have many problems or
at least any bondage at all indeed they
don't bring problems into their new
relation with Jesus so much as they now
confidently assert they bring pedigree
and privileges of the highest sort these
converts don't need jesus promises
freedom promised freedom they already
have it in Abraham and so then he
continues this notion of self idolatry
he says the Jews put their trust instead
of in Jesus in there
prior heritage and believed themselves
to be their own savings and Lords I
think this is hardly warranted from the
text itself and ultimately there is a
expression that I think is loaded with
you prior theological commitments the
Jews have to be converted from their
righteousness to a confession of their
ties to sin okay now I've picked out the
juiciest cherries of course there were
exceptions to this exegetical trend and
a number of commentaries did avoid
imputing these overly negative trays
such as pride and complacent to the Jews
so I've just listed a few early
exceptions there and for the you know
fuller publication details you can see
the handout and so my question now as I
continue researching this topic is how
to explain the exceptions or more
particularly to explain why some
commentators adopt this trope of Jewish
pride and others avoided I say avoid
because I would assume in any
commentator writing today would be aware
of the of the tradition since new
commentators tend to read out
commentaries so I just thought you know
there are a number of factors that could
influence you know why this might be the
case I'm not saying that anyone at the
moment is determinative until at least I
consult the wider sample that I can but
it can make a couple of observations one
pertains to the English language
commentaries in particular
and the other pertains to some very
recent German commentaries so at least
in the commentaries written in English I
observed that commentators who took a
certain methodological approach strictly
annotating the gospel text and reducing
multiple parallels from antiquity for
comparative purposes were less likely to
adopt the kind of judgmental
interpretation that denigrated the Jews
as proud perhaps this is because the
reader is invited to simply observe the
similarities between watch it what the
Jews are expressing in John 8 32 and
other ideas from the ancient sources and
so to maintain a neutrality about it the
contextual field provided by historical
analogy in those commentaries possibly
prevents the movement toward moral
judgment from gaining upper hand the
more significant problem is that i did
find happen to be in the more explicitly
pass really inclined commentaries such
as those of brodie and bruna but that's
not the whole story even in some english
language commentaries it's possible to
maintain neutrality without employing
historical criticism gaylo day is one
example but I found that that was more
evident in some recent German countries
that use the simpler expository method
of commenting on the text so let's take
a look at some of these none of these
have yet been translated into english
which i think is a shame because they
could have a positive impact so in 2001
we have decyl bingo writing now this is
interesting he doesnt sit back and get
this kind of critical distance in fact
he gets his voice his commenting voice
gets very involved in the text and in
order to explain what the dudes are
saying he actually continues to impute
speech to them and so basically the same
narrative mode continues in his
commentary and he says we Jesus Jesus
interlocutors live in the Abrahamic
covenant and we say that we are already
free and do not rely on another kind of
freedom for liberating truth is already
contained in the Abrahamic covenant not
in the word of the Sun
but in the great traditions of Israel
from which we have come and from which
we do not wish to lead there's nothing
judgmental at all about that by joining
his voice to that of the Jews so to
speak he gives them some kind of
legitimacy that the other commentators
have denied them same sort of thing with
Hardwick 10 he has written one in 2001
and he goes against this idea that we
saw in some of the earlier commentaries
that the Jews are misguided or
deliberately lying about their past
captivity he says it has nothing to do
with that on the contrary they speak of
their sense of religious freedom which
were downs to them as the chosen
covenant people of God something that
almost goes without saying he says the
appeal to Abraham as our Father is a
stereotypical Jewish expression of the
awareness of election now in context it
doesn't contain the kind of negative
sense that the similar kind of comet has
had in the prior commentaries by
Schnakenberg on the light so i wouldn't
say tune is taking a negative approach
here but he does actually cite strike
villa backs great handbook which kind of
approaches the New Testament from the
context of the Mishnah and Talmud and it
has its own particular agenda the
theological sort of presupposition that
Christianity or the New Testament
ultimately supersedes forbidding Judaism
so I'm a little bit cautious about that
one but on the whole the thrust of tunes
reasoning isn't delegate or ease so now
finally we've got my felt air-balled and
his was actually very very interesting
he says that the Jews response we have
never been slaves to anyone does not
mean an external political freedom but
expresses the dignity and notice the
different words he's using their of
Israel it's God's firstborn son their
covenant which throughout the ages
cannot be forfeited and through which
they maintain their inner freedom I'm
sorry for that content
but I think you get the sentence and he
says the Jews position cannot be morally
discredited and he's bringing into his
commentary here two of his predecessors
so the first one pride in self praise
that's Rudolph knippenberg terrible
interpolates that ! there to show his
his opinion of that and then their
self-confidence is delusional that's the
word of because it is it Lord gosh Anka
well Lord league tennis on it okay so
terrible is actually engaging with that
pride tradition and showing us what he
thinks but now he says the context is
about to theological convictions that
are brought together being children of
Abraham participating in a freedom
afforded by their covenant with God and
the faith in Jesus as the Messiah very
interesting okay so finally if this
reading of the Jews in John 8 32 is
proud nationalists is not a necessary
interpretive move where is it coming
from at this point I would gesture
toward unders wonderful work on German
biblical interpretation from the 1730's
up to the 1950s and you'll hear from him
later today so honors identifies well
argues that pejorative ideas of Jews and
Judaism quote formed part of the war
that runs through the European and
German cultural fabric and he
investigates two dominant research
traditions of his period that espouse
views about Judaism that are entirely
consonant with what I'm finding in the
modern exegetical commentaries on John
832 for example the Enlightenment
valuation of inner freedom went hand in
hand with opposition to a perceived
external legalistic Judaism and the
construction of it symbolic Jew who was
in
two works plenty of examples from on des
work show New Testament interpreters
from both traditions claiming that Jews
proudly asserted their guarantee of
salvation a pride that hindered their
ability to embrace true salvation in
Jesus scholars often spoke of the Jews
aristocratic pride had been God's chosen
people at toppers particularly popular
in the Imperial era other interpreters
of the time saw the juices embodying
national pride and a false sense of
emancipation now these views were
weren't necessarily connected with John
8 but were just generally part of
theological interpretation however much
later we can see God could tell the
general editor of the theological
dictionary of the New Testament running
in his own defense during the
denitrification period and he writes
never has a more negative
characterization of the Jewish religion
as a religion of privilege been made
than that found in John 8 44 and I think
it's these contexts and the fact that
this trope of Jewish pride and privilege
continues to be expressed so forcefully
in much of the Anglophone commentaries
on John 832 and more that it has morphed
into new manifestations should be a
cause for grave concern unfortunately
this troubling connection is practically
never acknowledged either in countries
themselves or in the secondary
scholarship and I think it ought to be
critically questioned okay thank you so
we have about 20 minutes for well maybe
about 15 minutes for conversation and
the floor is open for questions concerns
complaints John Collins hold on will we
get you a mic
is it fair to infer from your paper but
for the Gospel of John the ways have
part of which want to would you want to
put that in context of how you see
Christianity separating from Judaism I
used to say that that in the Gospel of
John the ways had parted and I may still
come back to that position in the future
I don't know right now I'm working on a
book on the parting on on the Johan I
community and considering this question
and what I'm playing with now is the
idea that perhaps if we look at the
Gospel of John as a rhetorical document
trying to engage in persuasion that may
be what it's trying to achieve is the
parting of the ways less than actually
reflecting a parting that had already
occurred I don't you know obviously I'm
still tentative about that but i think
that to me the Gospel of John all of
these readings that try to disarm it and
to talk about it as in ways that try to
reduce its emotional impact we are
missing the boat it is intended to play
on our emotions it's using a language
emotional language in order to create a
certain response in its readership and i
think that the response is one of
distancing from and pushing away from
and pushing Jews you know to create that
sense of distance so whether the
separation has happened or whether the
gospel is trying to make that happen I
think that's the dominant theme is the
idea that these things do not belong
together but that would you say but the
author did not consider himself a you
diocesan yes I would say that
i would say that and i think that that's
one thing that is demonstrable from the
gospel itself if you look at the gospel
uses the term you rehearsing information
that everybody in our field knows but
the gospel uses the term you die us or
more often plural you die about 70 times
it never uses that term to refer to
people who from the context are clearly
Jewish but who are believers so the
disciples are never referred to as you
do and Jesus himself is only once
referred to as a you die us and that's
by the Samaritan woman yeah so in that
sense i think that the gospel writer is
discouraging even those who come from a
Jewish background and seeing themselves
as you die and he is definitely you see
as jus rather than as thank you yes I
think so first to Ruth I really want to
commend your work I think it's very
important work just as we are looking at
older attitudes in 22 Jews and Judaism
in scholarship I think it's very very
important to go up to date as you do and
I think such study can be very
influential in really doing something
about the debate because I'm really
shocked when I see how little has
happened among the exegetes looking at
just those examples that you are showing
now I think that's very important also
very interesting than to contextualize
in different theological environments
but okay what what the catholic
environment the evangelical environment
the german more liberal environment etc
so i find that very interesting approach
then a question to a deal and this is a
little bit casting in the church but why
not and that is the question say that
John 422 would be authentic what happens
to the whole analysis of John I mean
that the salvation comes from the Jews I
don't know how you look at that question
I know bultmann for example I mean he he
simply put that in the [ __ ] footnotes
or as they put that part in the
footnotes without so much discussion on
what happens to the whole analysis yeah
well John for those of you that that
haven't memorized the Gospel of John
John 8 in John 8 42 occurs look for 22
John for is a conversation between Jesus
and a Samaritan woman in the course of
which Jesus says to the Samaritan woman
that salvation is from the Jews is of
the Jews i mean it's its egg right so
it's hard to it could have several
different meanings there and that's
often used as a kind of trump card for
those like myself that that are kind of
can't see too far beyond some of the you
know 844 and some of the highly negative
passages so what do you do with the
statement that salvation is from the
Jews if otherwise you want to argue that
that there is distancing and I don't
quite know what to do with it myself I
have to really figure that out in the
course of the book that I'm working on
right now but I think that it's not a
problem for my own construction of the
gospel to see Jesus the johannine Jesus
as referring to the origins of salvation
that somehow salvation is rooted in
something
to do with Jewish origins this could be
referring to himself although otherwise
he doesn't do that or it could be
fitting into the theme that I see their
of the what's often called replacement
theology that this that the central
symbols of Judaism Jewish rituals even
Jewish concepts the temple Torah etc are
both replaced by Jesus and some
fundamental sense but also refer forward
to Jesus so in that sense for 22 could
be understood as an acknowledgement of
of Jewish origins without reversing that
whole theme of hostility which comes
through very clearly and here my own
kind of moving toward the position that
Brown himself Ray Brown articulated in
his book the community of the Beloved
Disciple that the readers of the gospel
are not only people of Jewish origin
there's been a trend lately in johanan
studies to emphasize that John is an
entirely inner Jewish work that this is
another reason it can't be anti-jewish
because as Jews talking to Jews is the
same as reform and Orthodox and the
contemporary North American setting and
and so on but I think that there are
many aspects of the gospel that simply
make a lot more sense if you imagine a
varied audience or that of a group of
listeners that includes Gentiles and
Samaritans as well and if that's the
case he's asking a lot of Gentiles in
particular to adopt a certain Jewish
framework in order to become part of
this new community so I think that
that's where I would go with
I still needs of development hindi
thank you my question is is mainly for
Ruth but both Adele and Harry have
thought about both parts of my question
so I invite you also to contribute the
first part is the question of commentary
many of us this year are actually
thinking about commentary and what
constitutes commentary or what
commentary generates and it seems to me
from a literary standpoint you're asking
us to step back for a moment and reflect
on commentary itself as a new text or
new writing or new iteration in this
particular case of John so to think with
us in a literary way and then the second
part of the question is to ask you to
say a little bit more about the
political implications for what you show
with this genre which is itself a new
text and you seem in your history very
very rich and a very very impressive
history of interpretation you can call
it that you've laid out you've talked
about really two different trends one is
again I'm trying to parse it one is a to
contribute or to extend what I think you
would call not just an to Jewish but
anti-semitic rhetoric that like a
palimpsest kind of again and again on
the one hand and on the other hand
towards the end of your paper especially
but you alluded to it throughout your
paper is the ways in which certain
commentaries especially in the last
quarter of a century perhaps have been
somewhat more reflective especially
within the german-speaking community and
to ask you to reflect on their choices
and your choices as people who are all
writing commentaries and thinking about
about the gospel
okay um praise the question again two
parts one is just to reflect a little
more if you like about what the
implications are for thinking about
commentary yeah as a genre or as in as a
new gospel patient so that's kind of the
heaviness of what commentary can do
theoretically and religiously and then
to talk about I guess a different
parting of the ways that you're
articulating with respect to the history
of scholarship that you've laid out so
eloquently okay with reflections of what
commentary is I suppose I mean yeah come
true John is defined differently
depending on who you ask I think there
was a Miriam Webster dictionary
definition that referred to it as simply
a text that annotates a prior text if we
put it on a spectrum you could kind of
see that and then you could kind of see
another another writer whose name
escapes me has theorized the commentary
genre in an article recently published
in method and theory in the study of
religion and he would define comment the
comedy genre as attached that's
distinctly engaged with present concerns
trying to draw an ancient text from the
past into the present so he stick that
on the spectrum I think it's basically
like a hybrid of that and with the
critical gospel country genre you can
see commentators falling along plodding
along that quite you know predictably so
let me think so yeah the comment is it's
definitely a transformation of the of
the prior text so I brought up Jared
genet because he works with this notion
of the hypertext and the hi Bo text I
speak like that because I don't
pronounce the R so it sounds sounds the
same to you guys and sorry India I've
just lost the original fizzle that
that's that's perfect and me again the
second part is about the kind of
political implications in the tooth
cats that you're articulating which I
think could be a better segue to the
second half of our conference today the
Wayne right right right in terms of the
sort of 19th century and 20th century
kind of concerns that have brought into
the gospel text I think I think you've
demonstrated that they're not just
trying to make sense of John yeah but
there seem to be two very very different
trajectories one seems to line up very
closely with what Adele just did you
know with respect to the with respect to
the continuation of an anti-jewish and
even an anti-semitic rhetoric which has
a very different register yeah you know
in nineteen eighty or in 1783 and you
didn't again he hinted at the
implications but didn't develop them and
how shocked you were about ways in which
certain lines continued but they didn't
just continue they would transform him
there also after certain major events
that have implications for an to Judaism
on the other hand you were talking about
these correctives or even hyper
correctives that weren't apologetic in
the way that adult is describing but
very reflective on how to negotiate like
a to covenant theory which is young oh I
think for John commentary so it's see
nothing I think you were spelling out in
a larger project two different trends
yeah that's interesting you speak of
overcorrection and perhaps it is that
and I mean the whole thrust of my title
reproducing anti-judaism does draw on
what Adele was talking about in terms
are we talking about anti Judaism that's
there or something that's extrapolated
excessively or imposed upon the text and
I think yeah some of these commentators
have definitely picked up on the
negative portrayal of the Jews that's
present in John 8
and but they have really exaggerated it
pretty much but that's part and parcel
of what the Gosport self invites us to
do i think is to adopt a compliant
reading position to fall on one side and
in John 8 it seems to be either on the
Jew side or on Dez decide but in the
process you can detect trends and
interpretation that are simply
anachronistic and damaging and not
necessary and i think the recent kind of
what I've observed in the in the three
recent German commentaries that I did
get a chance to look at was yeah mainly
a reengagement with the with their own
tradition and and a way to try and read
the text maybe not correctly but
certainly with a concern to correcting
the abusive one of abuses but the
dangerous interpretations sort of given
in the past where to go from there I
don't know I know I am thank you that
where we go from here is to the coffee
hour an example of these questions will
be following us out to the the break but
but join me in thanking Adelaide Ruth
for our stimulating presentation
you